I never planned to become a climate
activists but things have changed at now
standing here as a climate activists I
ask you all to become one too here's why
and most importantly how ten years ago
when I was 13 years old I first learned
about the greenhouse effect back then we
spent 90 minutes on this issue and I
remember finding it quite irritating
that something so fundamental would be
squeezed into a single jerk of a lesson
some others irritation remained so when
I graduated from high school I decided
to study geography just to make sure I
was on the right track with this whole
climate change thing and this is when
everything changed this was the first
time I looked at the data at the science
behind the climate crisis and I couldn't
believe what I was reading like many
like many of you I thought that the
planet wasn't really in a good State I
had no idea that we are rushing into
this self-made disaster in such rapid
pace there was also the first time I
understood what difference it makes when
you consider the bigger picture take the
co2 concentration in the atmosphere for
instance the number one driver for
global warming yes this looks bad this
looks like we are on a pretty bad track
but it's only once you not just consider
the last 60 years but the last 10,000
years that you understand how terrifying
this really is and this is just one
aspect of the crisis we're seeing I'm
not going to get into details here but
let me tell you so much we are in a
point of history that the most
destructive force on the planet is
humanity itself we are in a
point of history that no scientist could
guarantee you that you will survive this
we are in a point of history that
humanity is creating an environment that
nuts that's not safe for humans anymore
yeah there was first year geography and
felt pretty overwhelmed but there was
good news the very same year I first
learned about all this leaders from
across the globe came together in Paris
to decide on the common target to limit
global warming to below 2 degrees
pictures went around the world and I was
told that history was made that day how
relieving right except something didn't
quite work out about this after this
agreement was signed things didn't
really get better actually they got much
worse decision makers and industries
leaders and politicians they went back
to business as usual
exploiting a livelihood like there's
literally no tomorrow building coal
power plans again and again even though
we know that needs to stop according to
the Paris agreement so why there was a
good development of course their
installations of wind and solar energy
all over the globe yes but these
positive changes are slow to slow in
fact so since the Paris agreement was
signed climate graphs keep racing to the
top smashing records every year the five
hottest years ever recorded were the
previous five years and in no time have
global emissions been higher than today
so there was seeing and understanding
the science on the one side but not
seeing answers not seeing the action on
the other side at that point I
I had enough I wanted to go to the UN
climate conference myself that very
place that was created to bring people
together to fix the climate except not
really apparently this was last year I
Trevor to the climate conference and one
if she find out what is really like what
this is about for political realists
this might be no surprise but I found it
hard to bear
that fossil fuel industries and
political leaders are doing everything
everything to prevent real change from
happening they are not keen to set
targets that are ambitious enough to put
us on a below two degree pathway after
all these are the only ones who benefit
from this climate crisis right the
fossil fuel industry generates profits
and political leaders well they look at
the next election at what makes them
popular and I guess that's not asking
the inconvenient questions there is no
intention for them to change the game
there is no country in the world that
either companies or political powers are
sanctioned for wrecking the climate with
on all the strangeness and the sadness
about this conference there was once
someone who was different someone who
seemed to be quite worried and that was
greater tune work I decided right there
that everything else seemed hopeless and
didn't seem to make sense so I joined
her climate strike right they had the
conference it was my very first climate
strike ever and an incredibly strange
setting just me and her sitting there
and this conference hall surrounded by
this busyness of the suit-wearing
conference crowd who had no idea what to
do with us and yet this felt more
powerful than anything I had expected in
a very long time and it was right there
that I felt it was maybe starts time
to start striking in Germany I was now
certain that no one else was going to
fix this for us and if there was just
the slightest chance that this could
make a difference it seemed almost
foolish not to give it a go so I
[Applause]
so I traveled back to Berlin I found
allies who had the same idea at the same
time and together we thought we'd give
this Friday's for future thing ago
obviously we had no idea what we're
getting into before our first strike
many of us including me had never
organized a public demonstration or any
kind of protest before we had no money
no resources and absolutely no idea what
climate striking really is so we started
doing what we were good in we started
texting texting and master´s night and
day everyone we could reach organizing
our first climate strike via whatsapp
the night before first strike I was so
nervous I couldn't sleep I didn't know
what to expect but I expected the worst
maybe it was because we weren't the only
ones who had been longing to have a
voice in political environment that had
seemingly forgotten how to include young
people's perspective into
decision-making
maybe but somehow this worked out and
from one day to the other we will over
the place and I from one day to the
other became a climate activists usually
in these kind of TED Talks
I would now say how it's overly hopeful
how we young people are going to get to
sort it how we're going to save the
future and the planet and everything
else how we young people striking for
the climate are gonna fix us usually but
this is not how this works
this is not how this crisis works here's
a twist today three and a half years
after that Paris agreement was signed
when we look at the science we find it's
still possible to keep global warming to
below two degrees
technically and we also see it still
possible to hold other disastrous
development
we're seeing such as mass extinction and
sorry degredation yes technically it's
just incredibly incredibly unlikely and
in any J in any case the world would
have to see changes which have never
experienced before
we'd have to fully decarbonize economies
by 2050 and transform the distribution
of powers that is currently allowing
those fossil fuel islands and political
leaders to stay on top of the game we
are talking of nothing less but the
greatest transformation since the
Industrial Revolution we are talking if
you want to put it that way we are
talking of a climate revolution in a
minimum amount of time we wouldn't have
a single further year to lose and in any
case for any of that change to happen
the world needs to stop relying on 1 or
2 or 3 million school strikers to sort
this out yes we are great we're gonna
keep going and we are going to go to
places no one ever expected us yes but
we are not the limits we are the start
this is not a job for a single
generation this is a job for humanity
and this is when all eyes on you for
this change to happen we will have to
get 1 million things sorted isn't
incredibly complex thing after all but
there are some things that everyone can
get started with bad news first
if you thought I would tell you now to
cycle more or eat less meat you fly less
or to go secondhand shopping sorry this
is not that easy but here comes the good
news you are more than consumers and
shoppers even though the industry would
like you to keep yourself limited to
that no me and you we are all political
beings and we can
we'll be part of this answer we can all
be something that many people call
climate activists yay
so what are the first steps for first
steps that are essential to get
everything else done for first steps and
that everyone can get started with for
first steps that decide about everything
that can happen after so what's that
number one we need to drastically
reframe our understanding of a climate
activists our understanding of an
understanding of who can be the answer
to this a climate activists isn't that
one person has read every single study
and is now spending every afternoon
handing out leaflets about vegetarianism
and shopping halls know a climate
activists can be everyone everyone who
wants to join a movement of those who
intend to grow old on a planet that
prioritizes protection of natural
environments and happiness and health
for the many over the destruction of the
plight climate and the wrecking of the
planet for the profits of the few and
since the climate crisis is affecting
every single part of a social of a
political and of a private life we need
climate activists everywhere every
corner but only in every room but also
every city and country and State and
continents second I need you to get out
of that zone of convenience away from a
business as usual it has no tomorrow all
of you here you are either a friend or
family member you are a worker a
colleague a student a teacher or in many
cases of voter all of this comes along
with a responsibility that this crisis
requires you to grow up to theirs the
company that employs you all that
sponsors you is on track of meeting the
Paris agreement there's your look a
parliamentarian know that you care about
this that you want this to be in
priority and every
election does your friend best friend
know about this do you read a newspaper
or write a newspaper great then let them
know you want them to report on this and
every issue and that you want them to
challenge a decision makers in every
single interview if you're a singer sing
about this if your teacher teach about
this and ever if you have a bank account
tell your bank you're going to leave if
they keep investing and fossil fuels and
of course on Fridays you should over
know what to do
thirdly leaving the Dern of convenience
works best when you join forces
one person asking for inconvenient
change is mostly inconvenient 2 5 10 100
people asking for inconvenient change
are hard to ignore the more you are the
harder gets for people to justify a
system that has no future power is not
something that you're either have or
don't have power is something you either
take or leave to other and it grows once
you share it we young people on the
streets we school strikers we are
showing how this can work out one
singers go striker will always be one
single school striker or greater tune
back to 5 10 1000 people strike in
school our movement and that's what we
need everywhere your pressure and number
four finally and this is probably the
most important aspect of all of this I
need you to start taking yourselves more
seriously if there's one thing I've
learned during seven months of
organizing climate action is that if you
don't go for something chances are high
that no one else were the most powerful
institutions of this world have no
intention of changing the game they're
profiting from most so there's no point
and further relying on them that's scary
I know that's a huge responsibility a
huge burden
everyone shoulders yes but this also
means if we want to attempts I have a
say in this we can be part of the change
we can be part of that answer and that's
quite beautiful right so let's give it a
try let's rock and roll let's flood the
world with climate activists let's get
out of the zones of convenience and
joined forces and start taking ourselves
more seriously imagine what this world
would look like where children would
grow up knowing their future was this
one great adventure to look forward to
nothing to be scared of what this world
would look like where the next climate
conference is this great happening of
people who come together who had heard
the voices of millions who would then
roll up their sleeves ready to create
real change you know I dream of this
world where geography classes teach
about the climate crisis as this one
greatest challenge that was won by
people like you and me
who had started acting in time because
that understood they had nothing to lose
and everything to win so why not give it
a go no one else will save the future
for us this is more than an imitation
spread the word thank you
[Applause]